John Smoltz is a hall-of-famer great
career has a World Series ring he's got
a little bit of everything yeah but if
John Smoltz could have one of the two he
could be a two-time World Series MVP two
rings and he's the MVP of both but not
be in the Hall of Fame or the career he
had where he has one World Series ring
he was not I think as Glavine was the
MVP and he is in the Hall of Fame I
would take the Hall of Fame career the
One World Series title spring and John
Smoltz the Major League Baseball Network
analyst right out of the gate right off
the plane John there's your question how
do you answer yeah that would be the the
Hall of Fame if you didn't throw in
about four rings in there that would
have been bad have been more enticing
but one more ring is not enough to to
change the course of destiny
what is how about this three-time World
Series champ two-time World Series MVP
but no Hall of Fame or your career that
got you into the Hall of Fame now you're
starting to mean three-time World CC I
mean World Series champs sounds really
really good and I could live with not
not going in the Hall of Fame when you
start talking about three wings four
rings
stuff like that that's that's that's
what we should have had anyway so you
know glad you brought it up that we
don't know that's all I wanted to talk
to you about John thanks how do you feel
about your bracket well it's almost it
was it's done but I'm gonna go back and
look at it I felt like the last few
years I've put too much pressure I'm you
know Michigan State so I'm gonna
probably just for the sake of being a a
fan I'm not gonna put that kind of
pressure on him this year in the bracket
I know they can feel it
when I'm you know I'm but I I like it
this year last couple years I didn't
like what I did kind of mailed it in and
I time I get back to to defending myself
like I did early on in this in this
bracket with you where I was basically
dominating and you weren't I need I need
to get back to that
you were the zion Williamson of filling
out brackets you were that good job you
were yeah I remember that one year that
I think I've got just about everything
right in the men's and the women's all
right why are we opening up the baseball
season in Japan because because they can
and because they have an opportunity
much like I mean we opened up I was part
of the broadcast in Australia that was
an unbelievable experience for me
personally I I know the team's the
Dodgers and the Diamondbacks you know I
had to make the necessary adjustments
and same thing here I here I've never
been over to Japan I hear everybody that
talks about it says it's unbelievable
you just have to deal with the mental
adjustment of playing two games and
coming back to spring training and then
getting ready to you know get on with
your season so to West Coast teams not
as bad and you know internationally
promoting the game and we've had you
know you think about Ichiro and just the
stars now that have come from abroad
it's been pretty impressive yeah but I
could still play a spring training game
or two games in Japan and still get the
crowds that come out to see Ichiro I
don't think that anybody said wow wait a
minute does this count or is this spring
training whether I'm gonna come out and
see this game I just you know what let's
plaits this is a game that still has
issues here at home and then we're gonna
try to you know accommodate Japan I
understand global expansion and all of
that John but you could have played two
spring training games over there made
sure Ichiro got to play and you would
have accomplished the same thing in my
opinion instead of hey go out there and
it's opening day and then come back and
do some spring training and then we'll
have another opening day here I don't
like it well you can have that opinion
the good news is the teams that have
been able to do that in the past you
know have gone on to the playoffs so
it's not it's not gonna interrupt them
too much and
and they're young they're strong
obviously everything will be fine yeah
it'll work it'll work out Mike Trout is
rich now I wonder yeah what
whose contract future would you rather
have Aaron judge or mookie betts wow
that's a great question I think you know
in the past you'd always say the Yankee
and their ability to always pony up a
little bit more but now with those two
dynamic players mookie betts you know
people have asked me this question if
you had to draft the - who would you
draft and I said it depends where I'm
drafting them - in other words if it's
going to be in Fenway Park Mookie Betts
is more important at Fenway Park then
let's say Aaron judge but Aaron judge is
more important in Yankee Stadium
I mean Mookie does things that most
center fielders would love to do and
he's playing that unique right field so
it's going to be fun to watch these two
and hopefully they stay healthy because
judge is just he's a freak at his size
and Mookie's a freak at his size bowler
but John I why wouldn't you want Aaron
judge with a Green Monster
well I'm just talking about I'm just
talking about the combo of defense and
offense they both bring unique skill
sets but I agree with you I mean what
what judge does at Yankee Stadium I
think it's like one third of his fly
balls or homeruns so some crazy number
it's crazy and so to go to right field
and just miss a ball is a homerun for
judge in Yankee Stadium and other people
not as much whereas Fenway you know
going to right field and right center I
mean nothing's going to hold Aaron judge
but the defensive component that Mookie
Betts brings to that part of the field
is unique and he covers so much that
defensively
I don't know and as judge is a great
defender I don't know that that would be
the same in Fenway Park it's a great
question
great debate and they're both going to
be smiling one day when they're able to
sign extensions or free agent contracts
talking to John Smoltz Major League
Baseball Network analyst a one time
World Series winner and what what was
that
just one time yeah I bet you did you did
one you did you did win one I mean I
know I know it's been a long time that I
I'm over it I'm over then I'm over it
one is so much better than none it is
okay when do you start to get concerned
if you're the Dodgers and Clayton
Kershaw when you start to have some kind
of symptoms issues to start the season
yeah that's so much because you realize
the resources they have to cover the
Dodgers are in a great position much
like the Yankees with some of their
injuries to their pitchers they're in a
position to withstand that kind of delay
and I don't think it's a big delay look
Clayton Kershaw is I'm sure and want to
want to continue the way he's always
gone about it but he knows he's going to
have to adjust accordingly into the
workload that he has so admirably done
for the Dodgers over the course of his
career make some adjustments mentally
allow pride to not be that's the hardest
thing when you're on top of your game
and you want to be the guy that is the
hardest transition is is is listening to
your team willingness to adjust and take
care of you know instead of 220 innings
now 210 and 200 and then eventually
maybe 180 190 that's what I think
they're gonna want to have happen so
that he is at his best at the end of the
year the start of the season every
player wants to make the start of season
but when you when you get to this point
in your career it's not the end of the
deal when you're delayed a few a few
weeks by the way we had Greg Maddux on
the show we finally got Maddux on the
show that was a I don't know couple of
ago and oh well he wasn't sharing
stories you know how Maddox is that he's
the silent assassin and he's always you
know downplays everything and then you
know I think he knew that we had had
some stories that were told on this show
about him and he he wasn't willing to
acknowledge those yeah his memory is not
really good these days but his memory
wasn't good back in the day it'll be in
the book that's never written about Greg
Maddux right correct correct
yes he is by far I mean they I know the
commercials of those sucky he's the most
interesting man in the world but but
that that belongs to Greg is the most
interesting man in the world were you
there oh no you weren't because he was
on the Cubs at the time when he had the
issue on the mound yeah with the Cubs
and Mark Grace how would you describe
that condition that Maddux had on the
mound that day it was not a lot of sleep
you know he just didn't have a lot of
sleep I think he was he was one of these
guys that he could I'll tell you what he
really could do is he could divert the
attention from whatever he wanted it to
be honestly he could he did it he
diverted it to his groin he did and he
would divert attention being brought on
in one way or another it was honestly as
I look back and it was really did it
I've told you he gave terrible
interviews so people stopped
interviewing him he gave you no
information he's the greatest of our
generation for what he did in pitching
and he just he liked he wanted you to
look over there you know just look over
there don't don't look at what's going
on over here
yes he was trout doesn't want to be
interviewed but I don't think he goes to
the extreme that Greg Maddux does
no and you know what I want to say this
I have a lot of respect for Mike Trout
being who he wants to be and not who the
whole world wants them to be and and I
think you know in this day and age where
everyone wants you know to be the face
of baseball get out do commercials if
the guy doesn't want to do it
he doesn't want to do it he just happens
to be the best player in our game and
he's being handsomely paid now and I
think everybody that's the one thing
about sports it's it's definitely an
easy answer when somebody says who's the
best player in baseball Mike Trout Thank
You John as always and we'll look
forward to your celebrity bracket
challenge for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]